Humans have been making
silk for centuries.
It's a coveted textile for
gowns, sheets, and robes.
But why is it so expensive?
Silk is the product
of the domesticated silkworm, Bombyx mori.
The caterpillars eat constantly.
They're fed mulberry
leaves five times a day.
After 45 days of munching and growing,
the worms are ready to mature.
They have a special
spinneret that secretes
one long continuous filament.
That's the silk.
The silkworms spin this
filament into a cocoon.
Then the caterpillar
begins its transformation.
Except, this is when
silk producers butt in.
The cocoons are steamed.
This cleans them and
kills the pupa inside.
If the pupas were kept alive,
they would degrade and break the silk.
Then the cocoons are unraveled
to reveal around half a
mile of usable filament.
Filaments are joined to
create a thread thick enough
to weave into fabric.
One yard of silk fabric
costs approximately $100.
What makes it worth the cost?
We spoke to a few experts
on the subject to find out.
Shawne Jacobs is the creative director
and president of wedding dress
design house, Anne Barge.
Consumers accustomed
to synthetic materials
like polyester expect perfection.
Professor Daniel Nicodemo
credits silk's price tag
to its thermal conductivity
and sturdiness.
It's also easily dyed and
doesn't cause skin irritation.
So what do you think?
Is silk worth the cost?